the first issue of forbes magazine was
published on september 15 1917 today
marks 100 days until the magazine's
100th anniversary to celebrate the
upcoming centennial issue Forbes is
featuring some of its favorite covers
and stories they focus on innovation and
entrepreneurs Randal Lane the editor
Forbes magazine joins us here at the
table good morning good morning has the
mission of Forbes remained the same over
a hundred years what's fun is the
mission has remained the same for a
hundred years Forbes was the first
magazine ever to treat people and
entrepreneurs as the people driving
businesses of course there's no such
thing as a business running itself it's
people running businesses and we've
always been about the people running
businesses what has changed is who's
running the businesses we're seeing
entrepreneurship I mean people coming
out of college today they don't want to
go work up the corporate ladder they
want to start a business I want to be an
entrepreneur and we see that we see more
women we see younger entrepreneurs we
see people of color we're seeing all of
America want to embrace that fourth
mission it's kind of nice so Randall to
take a look back at what it tells us
about our history and who we are
starting with a cover story from 1989
nope it focuses on the Soviet Union's
interest in computing back then we had
to call me here in 28 years before the
current hearings where was a cover story
looking at all these Russians were
getting interested in computers and just
when the Soviet it wasn't even Russians
the Soviets back then and it was a cover
story on their interest in that there's
something here and we actually talked
about hacking 28 years ago Russian
hacking so you know you can see history
all the way through it survived 100
years because it focused on
personalities based on people people
want to read about people and anybody
who's ever run a business knows that
there's no such thing as a machine
making decisions people are making
decisions and when you look at business
as a collective of decisions and about
people making a difference in changing I
mean in the very first forms the ideas
business was not organized to pile up
millions it was organized to create
happiness
to solve this as leaders became
celebrities like Steve Jobs and others
absolutely
I love how a cover 2 tells us history
right 1945 soldiers raising the Iwo Jima
flag during World War two
Forbes turned the whole cover into a
basically an ad for war bonds I mean
that's when you saw all the country
coming together the
we're and it was not paid for footy free
ad on the cover basically support the
war effort different times not many
publications make it to their 100th year
anniversary there's a great look pretty
good right really good really good why
do you think you guys are survived when
others happen it really is in some way
to think we've executed well but really
it's the world has come to us where it's
not about corporations and it's not
about it's not about numbers it's about
people and and we've always been about
the people and right now we're in the
era where you can anybody give you
twenty two years old and have an idea
and you can execute it and that's what
we've always been about but businesses
like you do a lot of conferences to a
place to bring people to the right
network and it's become a community I
mean we look at our under thirty
franchise where we bring young
entrepreneurs and then they all come
together for our under thirty summer
where we have seven thousand young
entrepreneurs who are bonded by the
force brand but they all come together
and they could change for the world we
have a women's summit coming up next
week where women entrepreneurs come
together so it really is a magazine
creates mold you know websites events we
have a snapchat geofilter coming out
tomorrow where they give us up on the
cover force what makes a 100th
anniversary cover can't wait before do
it yeah can I'm you too
nice to have you thank you